and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist and today we're gonna talk
about financial independence we're gonna
talk about spending habits we're gonna
talk about solving all your money
problem we're gonna talk about fire yes
we are you know it's it's fascinating
I find that when we talk about money
sometimes we're often just talking about
all the stupid things that we waste our
money on and I think that's gonna be a
reoccurring discussion point today and
we have a guest in the studio today
Travis Shakespeare is here he's the
director of the new documentary playing
with fire you can check it out I playing
with fire CEO we'll be talking more
about that as well
but before we dive into today's
questions Travis can you talk to us
about what what is fire fire it's so hot
it is man it's the hottest thing going
you ever seen the Sun exactly like that
fiery fire stands for financial
independence retired early so there's a
lot of controversy around that phrase we
can get into if you want later but it's
basically people love the create
controversy around everything I do oh
I'd like to retire early yeah you idiot
you idiot - that totally yeah you're
privileged no at the the greatest
objection is like so it's basically
about a group of Millennials who have
left mandatory work in their early 30s
to 40s by living very values-driven
lives being frugal in some respects and
investing very early and very often so
you'll typically find like a prototype
is like somebody who's like in their 30s
and they've got a million dollars in the
bank and now they're living off of the
interest and capital gains which is
basically done through something called
the 4% rule so if you have a million
dollars invested you can live off of
forty thousand dollars a year without
depleting the portfolio yeah
theoretically in perpetuity but the
first thing that people say is well why
would you want to retire when you're in
your
30s that's insane like don't you want to
be slaved enslaved and trapped and like
the chained to your desk like us for the
rest of your lives
I think conflating the idea of
retirement and also the idea of not
working and retiring doesn't necessarily
mean I'm never going to work on
something I'm passionate about it means
you're not tethered to a desk job or a
corporation you could still do those
things if you want to though right
that's right I guess there's just no
better word for leaving mandatory work I
mean if you look at like people
throughout history I you know I was
talking to one of the British bloggers
recently and we kind of happened on the
idea that the fire movement is kind of
like the agricultural aristocracy of
England so they lived on passive
agricultural income mmm you know I mean
a lot of that was generational wealth
which is different from what these folks
are doing because most of them aren't
inheriting money but these are the
people who wrote policy who wrote novels
who did playwriting you know like I mean
these are the people who contributed a
great deal to culture but they didn't
have a mandatory job in the traditional
sense and they may have not been like
driving Rolls Royces things obviously
not back then well no I mean only if
they were really lucky right right right
exactly all right let's go and dive into
some questions today our first question
is from Melissa in Delaware I am in
quite a bit of debt living paycheck to
paycheck and using pretty much all of
your pay for rent and bills how do you
necessarily get out of debt when you're
living this way and for years I've
always put it off and said okay well one
day I'm going to make a lot more money
and that's when I'll be able to pay off
debt and I found that I've just been
saying that for so many years that I
don't know how many more years I will be
saying that because I've been living
paycheck to paycheck for a long time and
I can't quite get out of this cycle so
what is the best way to get out of debt
when you're not making enough money to
pay the debt off and you're only making
enough money to make ends meet dude I
used to have that exam exact attitude
like when I was making you know minimum
wage or I think eventually I got a job I
was making like 10
bucks an hour and I'm like okay I'm not
gonna worry about saving for retirement
right now I'm not I'm not going to worry
about paying off any debt because one
day I'm gonna make $50,000 a year I
don't have a plan to get there right but
I it's gonna happen eventually there's
some hypothetical future where I'm going
to make unlimited amounts of money I
don't know how but of course it's gonna
happen because I'm awesome and then I
started making $50,000 a year and what
did I do
I'm like oh this isn't enough money hey
I took on more debt and then I just like
perpetuated the lie of like oh when I
make $90,000 a year that's when I'll be
able to live debt-free now Travis you
probably see this a few words that stood
out to me in fact if I were to rephrase
Melissa's question I would just say how
do I achieve financial freedom when my
entire paycheck is eaten up by bills and
those bills for her she says they pay
for the basics right you know she she
used some words like debt she's words
like living paycheck to paycheck but
also acknowledging that she wants to get
out of debt I imagine that you stumble
across a lot of people were saying well
financial independence is so far out of
reach for me because I can't even I
can't even get out of debt at this point
yeah I mean my personal story was I was
still in a lot of debt by the age of 40
years old so I was $40,000 in student
loan debt at 9% interest because I
consolidated when they told me that the
interest rates are the lowest I would
ever see in my lifetime I was in credit
card debt and I was living the lottery
mentality that someday somebody was
going to just shower me with money like
you said because I'm awesome and it took
my father passing away and me and Harry
was a schoolteacher so I inherited a
small amount of money about $75,000 that
was my big payday right this was the I'm
awesome that was the I am awesome moment
and I'm very grateful for you know what
he did in terms of saving that money and
passing it on to me but for the first
time in my life I was debt-free so I am
completely empathetic to people who have
racked up a lot of debt and seemed to be
very much under that and it's just very
hard to get out from under particularly
when you look at things like credit
cards
that are charging you between 20 and 30
percent interest which is just insane
and I think that people don't really
understand what that means I think if
you put that money if you put $10,000
into a calculator at 30 percent interest
and run it for 10 years into the future
and look at what that actually means
maybe you'll think twice before you lay
your credit card down for another pair
of shoes where you sign up for a new
credit card because oh I'd be dumb not
to it saves me 15% on this Banana
Republic pair of khakis exactly so - you
know to be fair once you're already in a
lot of debt and that's where this
society loves to keep us you are already
at a disadvantage so your options are to
earn more money you know and reduce your
spending but yes now on this podcast we
give simple advice but simple is not
easy simple is very very difficult in
fact that's what I love about the
documentary you guys did with playing
with fire like you've got Scott and
you've got Taylor who are living this
lavish lifestyle and they make the
decision that they want to save more
money so that's exactly what they do
they find out a way to reduce their
costs at first and it shows this process
of them doing that and it's real it's
not like this very happy fairytale story
of like oh we decided to be financially
independent and now we are end of movie
like it's a beautiful story about the
struggle of doing that and in that's
really what I wanna tell Melissa is like
Melissa it's going to be very very hard
for you to get out from underneath of
that debt but yes those two things
making more money there's no shame in
driving for uber or delivering pizzas or
whatever taking on some kind of side gig
there's no shame in getting a second job
temporarily to kind of help get yourself
above water and yeah I mean what do we
used to tell our employees Josh when
they ask for a pay raise yeah the
quickest way to give a pay raise is to
spend less money right and and that was
really the plan in fact Sean if you
could put a link in the show notes to
this episode to an essay I wrote a few
years ago about financial freedom it was
a five-step
but it was specifically titled five
difficult steps to get out of debt right
and difficult because it is simple but
it can still be difficult to do
unfortunately I didn't have my mother
died I was 28 she left me two dollars
and 39 cents which wasn't enough at all
on black and lose it it wasn't enough to
pay off my six figures worth of debt and
so I had I made really good money in the
corporate world throughout my twenties
spent even better money and as a result
had amassed a lot of debt because I had
a a good job or all sensibly good job
people were willing to give me lines of
credit and so I was always spending more
than I made I was I was making great
money but still living like Melissa
paycheck to paycheck and I thought well
like Ryan thought well I would to make
more money eventually oh I'll become a
CEO but or CEO oh or it didn't matter I
was not making enough money and I had
accumulated a lot of debt so I had to
come up with a plan and that plan
involved the two things that you just
said I had to make more money and I did
some things even when I was in the
corporate world I was I was this before
uber but I was delivering pizzas to pay
off credit card debt in evenings and
weekends I was starting to sell
everything
eBay and Craigslist became my best
friend anything that was sort of in the
house that I was not using it was great
for the minimalism thing too because I
was starting to pare down and getting
getting rid of these things and no
longer added value to my life I wasn't
selfishly clinging anymore I was letting
go of those things making pennies on the
dollar from what I paid for them but I
wasn't getting any value from them at
all so that was another way for me to
make more money but ultimately the best
pay raise ever gave myself was to live
within my means and then actually really
live below my means when I walked away
from the corporate world I took about a
90 percent pay cut
I'm a $23,000 that first year but I was
actually more financially secure because
I was making better decisions with a
little bit of money and the other
resources I did have and so if I'm
talking to Melissa I'm gonna say hey
money is one resource but what are your
other resources your time your attention
your energy your skills your towel
and these are things that you can also
use to earn more income especially as
you're trying to pay off debt I actually
applaud you for feeling the pain that
you're feeling right now Melissa she's
asking the right questions yeah that
pain is actually good this pain is is
leading you toward I need to have some
sort of behavioral change because this
debt is not good I don't like this
anymore I don't want to feel this way I
want to feel different and I find the
people in the fire community feel a lot
different they feel free they do feel
free I mean you know debt is something
that is like a ball and chain and I mean
I really think people like Melissa have
to start considering debt like a poison
because it is a kind of poison in your
life it's a spiritual poison and the
fire movement has figured out a way to
sort of cleanse themselves of that
poison by taking their power back yeah
yeah know what I love about the
documentary too is it's not just a bunch
of like rich Millennials who are
retiring early I mean it's it's it's
your everyday people I mean yeah they're
making more than minimum wage but you
know they're not bringing in six figures
a year and that's how they're becoming
financially independent it's it's like
your everyday family two or three four
person family that is able to become
financially independent there's one
thing though
there's one step I think we're skipping
over here with Melissa what's that she
has got to put a budget together yeah so
I have people email me well when I was
taking on new mentoring clients
I still mentor but I'm not taking on new
clients but uh people would email me
they'd be like Ryan I am so poor I can't
afford your mentoring but I really need
your mentoring and I'm like I will give
it to you for free please send me your
budget put your budget together and let
me see it and then I will absolutely
give you free mentoring I have not had
one person take me up on that and then I
had I had one friend who was complaining
to me about money and I was like you
know I'd love to help you let me see her
budget and she's like Ryan that's
insulting
I'm poor I don't need a budget to know
that I'm poor and I'm like if you don't
know how poor you are though like you're
doing yourself a disservice so Melissa
step one is you've got to get clear on
what your budget is that is going to
help you know exactly where your money
is
the only thing I want to mention to
Melissa is you gotta find the leverage
to spend less money or to make more
money but I'll tell you one thing I know
in your documentary Vicki Robbins talks
about this a little bit your money your
life she wrote that book back in like
the early nineties late 80s I mean yeah
it was it's a great book but here's a
new version of it now I believe oh yeah
she does she misses him in the men's
game in it that's right yeah so yeah
check that book out for sure your money
your life you can put that in the show
notes Sean if you don't mind but you've
got to find leverage to be able to spend
less money so what Vicki did like she
was on Oprah back in the day and she had
this like rack of clothes and she's like
look at this jacket this jacket was $400
it was on sale for a hundred you were
stupid not to buy it
but this hundred-dollar jacket if you're
making 8 bucks an hour I mean you're
working a day and a half you're giving
up you know 10 hours of your time or 12
hours of your time to buy this jacket so
Melissa with every purchase that you
make like you've got to be able to look
at that cup of coffee and say oh man
this is four dollars of my time if
you're making a minimum wage in Delaware
looks like 875 and after taxes that's
like $8.00 and you're working a half
hour for that cup of coffee or for that
$20 mil you're working three hours
you've got to be able to put it in that
perspective to to motivate yourself to
spend less I mean little tricks like
that will help is there any other
leverage you think there's actually the
biggest leverage points are housing
transportation and food so housing is if
you look at your budget that's always
the biggest chunk so whatever you can do
to reduce your housing like people are
like oh just stops just stop buying
lattes you know you're not gonna become
a millionaire by just stop buying lattes
but if you can get your housing cost
under control and your transportation
cost under control that's the big-ticket
item so it may require sacrifice
somebody like Melissa I mean listen when
I lived when I first moved to LA like I
had roommates forever mmm like literally
forever because this is an expensive
city but by maintaining a roommate
situation it allowed me to save a ton of
money so maybe it's time to get a
roommate or if you can find a way to
she's probably not in this position but
a lot of the fire people will buy a
duplex and they'll find a really cheap
duplex and they'll renovate one side and
they'll live in the other side and basic
have somebody else paying their mortgage
you know you know and then
transportation like this culture loves
to tell you that you need a new car
every three years or something right
nobody needs a new car ever actually you
can get you can get pie on you know a
$5,000 car pretty much anywhere and it's
a reliable safe piece of Transportation
you know so you look at that and then
food costs obviously are that's that's
where you can really like adjust you
know what you're doing because you know
mister money mustache shoes one of the
core funny in five years of the
financial independence movement has this
one post that I love which basically
breaks down your food cost by calorie
like he's such an engineering nerd that
he's optimized like how many almonds you
know you need to eat every day you know
to get your protein in and you know it's
only like this many pennies you know on
the dollar I'm gonna have to find that
it's a great post you know put a length
of that in the show notes as well
Melissa I'm gonna send you a copy of our
book essential there's 12 different
chapters in here on the twelve different
areas of well twelve areas that Ryan and
I identified it's an essay collection
150 different essays breaking down the
12 categories of intentional living and
one of those chapters one of those
categories has to do with finances so I
think you'll find a lot of value in the
financial chapter as well as the other
chapters if you like our podcast you
like the audiobook version of that so
Sean if you could reach out to Melissa
send her the audiobook or if you want
the book book or the e-book we're happy
to send those to you as well Ryan what
time is it it is time for our lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media indeed we do so we're at
the minimalists on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and Duren lightning round this
where Ryan and I do our best to answer
every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like and now you can
find all of these quotes in one place
thanks to our good friend Jessica Lynn
Williams over at minimal Maxim's com now
Travis what we actually do is we monitor
on a bit we ramble and then Sean
tweezers out something pithy like a
moment ago you said you said debt is
would you say a spiritual I said it's a
spiritual poison that is a spiritual
poison put that in
show knows podcast Shawn what's our
first question Ryan our first question
is from Ian what advice do you have for
someone working a minimum wage job and
wants to save and invest and the money
that the person earns well my pithy
answer here is we can't maximize life
with a minimum effort now a minimum wage
job doesn't mean there's necessarily
minimum effort here I've worked several
minimum-wage jobs like was yeah there's
a dishwasher busboy there was a lot of
effort there what I mean by this is we
do need to put an effort to earn more
money if if we're working a minimum-wage
job I don't think minimum wage jobs are
necessarily meant to sustain us long
term in fact we've had TK Coleman on the
podcast four different times now and he
is an advocate of actually abolishing
the minimum wage he thinks that the
minimum wage was was created because of
well there are racist reasons that the
minimum wage was was created and we
could dive into that some other time
with him I'm sure but his point is that
the minimum wage is is it's not what we
should be striving for we should not be
striving for the minimum what one other
pit the answer here is money isn't
everything but it's also not nothing I
think too often we are we are driven by
money and I'm actually finding the
people in in the fire community in
particular it seems like it's driven by
money at first because that's the all
sensible subject right but it's it's
just the opposite of that it's driven by
values so living a more intentional
well-rounded meaningful life and we do
need some money to do that but of course
we don't need all the money in the world
to do that we don't need a billion
dollars in order to be happy no I mean
actually the genius of the movement is
that they've they figured out that time
is the most important thing in life
right and money is infinite right it
literally is infinite I mean we print
more and more every day like as if you
know it doesn't make any difference it's
like YouTube video right yes that's
exactly true
but time is finite you know we don't
know how much time we have left on the
planet and Scott and Taylor in our film
for instance you know they what
triggered them was that they had a baby
and they were like wait a minute we're
spending every single working hour of
our day working to support the lifestyle
that we think that we should have which
is taking away all this precious time
from our us with our little girl and by
the way that's a lifestyle that probably
other people think they should have and
that's why you think you should have it
we and it's we've been marketed to 5,000
marketing messages a day if you live in
a big city 500,000 discrete bits of
input every day we're constantly
barraged by by other people's ideas
other people's ideas of how we should
live our life so quite often it isn't
like that's the life I really want that
is the life that someone else wants so I
should want it too that's right I mean
it's a it's just indoctrination through
advertising yeah yeah and so so if we're
given Ian's advice here he works a
minimum wage I mean the simple advice is
you have to you have to earn more money
at this point yeah I mean and that
doesn't mean go quit your job tomorrow
Ian but it does mean like find a way to
move on to something else or even if you
got to get like a second part-time job
or something again like that spend less
earn more like that's how you're gonna
be able to save my pet the answer is
it's really going back to the budget
it's nearly impossible to save money if
you don't have a detailed budget and if
you're making a minimum wage I would say
that you need a budget more than most
people because your resource is limited
when we're talking about budgeting
really what you're talking about is how
do I allocate my resources right and a
calendar is a way to budget your time
the most important resource for me I
actually think attention is your most
precious resource and that's a sort of a
subset of time in a way right it's like
because we all have the same amount of
time in a day we have 24 hours how we
spend it our attention and what energy
we give to these things is really how
I'm budgeting my time so how are you
budgeting your time right now are using
your time to maybe develop some skills
that will aid you in the workplace later
or
using your time and your attention - to
read more instead of pacifying yourself
so that ultimately you're gonna develop
into a person who does command a greater
income it's not about going out tonight
finding the better job but there are
ways there are sort of side hustles
we've had Chris Guillebeau on the
podcast his book about and he and his
podcasts about side hustles these are
people who aren't trying to earn a full
time living but setting up intentional
side hustles to earn an additional
income so that you can be more
financially independent yeah like if you
can make a hundred or 200 bucks extra a
month I mean that goes a long way in the
budget also it's not it's not this magic
bullet answer it's not like oh now you
have a budget now everything everything
is fine that's just like the first step
to this very very difficult process it's
about noticing yeah absolutely and Shawn
please put a link to every dollar I mean
that's the budgeting app that Mariah and
I use we've got an account that we share
it's Dave Ramsey's tool it is it's one
of my favorite budgeting apps that I use
do you have a budgeting and app that you
would recommend I anything just use a
spreadsheet yeah I actually just use a
pencil and paper yes oh so that's what
Mariah and I used to do and the
spreadsheet it does work every dollar I
like it just because you can kind of
it's just a little bit but for me it's a
little just a little bit better than a
spreadsheet but for some people the
spreadsheet might work better whatever
it is just get a budget I think that the
apps are kind of useful because they
game a PHY yeah the whole thing i which
i think is actually very useful because
you're tricking your brain into a
dopamine hit like one of the things that
I loved when I was early on in my path
to financial independence was every time
I put a dollar in the bank I got like a
little dopamine hit and it actually
became sort of addictive I was like oh
wow I'm up to ten bucks I'm up to a
thousand dollars and you know but when
you hit 10,000 you're like whoa yeah
like I'm killing it right now you know
it's a very exciting feeling I have one
suggestion based on what you were saying
about time and attention which is
education you know it's very easy to say
to somebody who has a minimum wage go
out and and get another job I mean these
people are killing themselves let's face
it right you know if you're writing the
bus and like making I don't even know
what the minimum wage to average on
average is now it's like 12 bucks an
hour
oh you ever done one of the average I
know federal minimum wage is like 750
750 federally we live in California so
we're a little better all right yeah but
um but it's still really really tough
now if instead of if you could take a
chunk of your time and try to educate
yourself into another skill you know
like if you're working at McDonald's and
getting another job is an option but
instead of taking that time to get
another job you spend six months
learning how to become a welder or
something that's a tangible skill or
coding or whatever it is that you can
then make the leap I think that that to
me would be a long-term solution to the
short-term problem of being stuck as
working poor basically yeah I totally
agree
yeah just saying get a second job that
is easier said than done and one thing I
would add to that is don't confuse
schooling with education there are many
ways to to gain an education without
going for you the proper four-year
degree in fact many four-year degrees do
not yield more income necessarily a lot
of them might you know if you're going
to to go to school for nursing or or
some of these fields that are in high
demand but there are other fields that
require maybe a training program or some
sort of vocational school or or maybe
just an apprenticeship apprenticeship
you can go down to your your dad's
friend who knows how to fix cars you
know and like just offer to help for
free in order to learn you know the
mechanics and next thing you know you
can end up working at BMW as you know a
staff mechanic those guys make really
good money actually yeah definitely
prima Rights why would someone need to
be financially independent if they're a
minimalist and what is the first baby
step to start the journey toward
financial independence well my short
answer here is money won't solve all
your problems but it will solve your
money problems she's asking about the
baby steps here I mean if the first baby
step is before you even get to what Dave
Ramsey might even call the baby steps
right is having a budget but then being
debt-free was really ultimately the the
first step
word financial independence for me in
order to travel in the direction you
want to travel you first must get out of
the crater that you're in and and and
that for me was like really getting
laser focused on paying off debt to get
out of that crater and then you can
determine what is financial independence
look like for me Travis what do you
think about about I mean obviously
getting out of debt but then where'd of
where the folks go from there I think
that those three big-ticket items the
housing the transportation and the food
I think that's that's where you want to
really get your budget under control and
then the other genius of the financial
independence movement is to invest early
and invest often so every 10 years
whatever money you've got invested will
basically double but that also means
that every 10 years you wait to invest
means that you have to double your
savings right right so if you wait until
you're 40 like I did and you know have a
decent job finally you're you're having
to I had to save two four times the
amount of money that I would have if I
started saving when I was in my 20s in
order to reach the same end point right
at 65 if I had a traditional retirement
so if I could tell my younger self one
thing even if I only had five dollars or
20 dollars to invest a month it's worth
it it absolutely is because that's the
magic of compound interest right the if
you're 25 years old and you invest $25 a
week you're gonna end up with roughly a
a million dollars by the time you are 65
if you get a good interest rate and
everything sort of works out well but
that is because of compound interest now
obviously you'll want to be able to
invest more than that and hopefully
retire even sooner than that but but
that tells me that even if you're
working minimum wage and you're able to
set aside $25 a week the beauty the
magic of compound interest means that
you're gonna be so much better off and
your future self is going to thank you
as a result hi n Stein called it the
eighth natural wonder of the world or
something like that that's beautiful
yeah you know minimalism doesn't mean
you're you're poor or you live without
money
I mean minimalists are not necessarily
allergic to money so my pet the answer
is money isn't everything but it is
necessary even for minimalists isn't
Dean all right looks like we have a
bunch more surprise questions this week
about a specific plan to pay off debt
about different budgeting methods about
charitable giving on a budget about
transportation expenses about going into
debt for your passion about mortgages
and many many many more questions in
fact Ryan we've got a record number of
questions I don't even think we can get
to all of them also we have an article
here 11 steps to retire by age 50 and if
you want to hear all that you can listen
to this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different long-form
maximal episode on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about
topics we don't usually discuss in
public plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast and keep it 100
percent advertisement free when you
subscribe to the minimalist private
podcast on patreon you'll also receive a
personal link so that our maximal
episodes play in your favorite podcast
app find all the details and all the
good stuff over at the minimalists
dot-com slash support also it's probably
worth noting that we are now capping our
patreon support and we're more than
halfway there at this point and by the
way our patrons have doubled over the
last four or five months and so well
we'll be getting there relatively soon
we're trying to keep it a private space
and we've identified what is enough for
us and 6,000 people is enough it's
enough to pay podcast Shawn and Jordan
know more and Jessica and also ourselves
and never pepper our podcast with
advertisements Ryan what else you got
for us this week as always being
informed is more important than ever
especially with something like finances
or being financially independent I mean
you know like I said on the podcast we
give simple advice but simple and easy
so go get a book and and figure out what
you can do to help yourself become
financially independent I know
great starting point is Dave Ramsey's
Total Money Makeover that books gonna
help you get out of debt so I want to
encourage people who are listening to
this to read more and get informed and
also Josh I got some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners check him
out hey Morris this is Christina calling
from Waterloo Ontario Canada I just
listened to your career podcast and
wanted to call to say how much I loved
it I think it's so important to find
what you're passionate about and just go
for it kind of continue to cultivate
that passion and push through the low
parts I actually started writing a
fashion blog back in 2013 and it's
continued to grow from there I said need
to be a style coach and once my own side
business was past November and now I
work one-on-one with people to develop
their own personal style I've always
been passionate about promoting local
shopping in my community but I realized
after listening to the podcast that I'm
going to focus even more on teaching my
clients on how to shop according to
their values more eco-friendly and
really help them minimize their closets
I just wanted to thank you guys for
helping me realize this and for all you
guys do hi guys this is Marley in
Cleveland Tennessee and I am a newbie to
your podcast and I've already hooked
maybe it's because you spoke about one
of my favorite subjects creativity I
want to share how liberating it is that
you give people permission to practice
failing when I learned the wisdom that
the brick wall of frustration is the
part of the creation creative process it
set me free once I knew that this was
part of the process I could know where I
was and go on to the next steps of
incubating my creative idea strategizing
new ideas and collaborating with others
so at that brick wall the frustration I
didn't quit and go home but I kept at it
seeing it through to the Success moment
also a tip on the 1/2 to versus the get
to in your creative process one inquiry
you could ask is the Eee test does this
heavy
not to be confused with easy because our
life's creativity isn't always easy
but does it flow with these does it have
great energy and do I enjoy it
that's when you know in your bones that
you are doing something you love alright
y'all thanks again to Travis Shakespeare
for joining us today check out his new
documentary playing with fire you can
find all the details learn more over at
playing with fire dot co and real quick
4 right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalists have you checked out our
side project it's called minimalism dot
life and the website is minimalism dot
life yes apparently that is an extension
for those of you who don't know I nted
this out Ryan and because we've been we
have a team of writers over there who
have been doing a phenomenal job on the
journal side of things so for those of
you who don't know what minimalism dot
life is it's a it's curating the best of
simple living
so like well-being that's Ryan's and
mines wheelhouse but also minimalist
design and so it could be like
architecture or other design aspects our
friend Carl from minimally Simo is over
there and also minimalist travel Alberto
from five style so we all three teamed
up and we have a team of writers over
there who are also writing about these
topics and you can find that in our
journal you can get on the email list
over there you can just go to minimalism
about life you can find all of these
journal articles as well here's a few of
them one is called the next step the
next step there's one called be aware
there's one called the renegade
minimalist the elephant in the room
techno minimalist curating a natural
home you don't need much to be happy
controlling the floodgates the trouble
with clothes discussing space a life
edited and many many more there's also
something over there called inside
minimalism you can check that out also a
bunch of free wallpapers for your phone
or for your tablet or your computer
check all those out at minimalism dot
life you can also follow minimalism life
on Twitter and Instagram
and check out all the beautiful curated
photos and words and quotes and
minimalism life and new stuff comes out
each week if you have a question comment
or minimalism tip for our podcast leave
us a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our e-mail list over at the
minimalists comm you'll also receive our
simple Sunday emails each week for our
added value this week let's listen to
NOAA Gunderson's new song it's called
Robin Williams which perfectly
illustrates the sort of ephemerality but
also well I think it was like the
simultaneous seriousness and absurdity
of life and Robin Williams perfectly as
a human being encompass that I thought
about this because we did that episode
with with Jamie kills teen recently and
he was good friends with with Robin
Williams and life is simultaneously
serious there are things that are
serious we have to take seriously but
also a lot of life is absurd
and the things that we think are serious
are often absurd and the things that we
think are absurd we should all probably
take more seriously and I think a lot of
that episode today the episode today was
about that especially the the patreon
episode that we recorded with with
Travis we got into some of these things
that we could probably better spend our
money on a more serious approach to to
our money anyway here is Robin Williams
the new song Robin Williams from Noah
Gunnarsson's new album lover and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listen y'all we'll see you
next time minimus